♪ ♪
>> Sean: A CLOUD OF CORRUPTION
LOOMS OVER THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN,
HUNTER BIDEN IS TRYING TO
SALVAGE HIS FATHER'S CAREER AS
HE IS FOUND AT THE CENTER OF
THESE ISSUES OF CRONYISM.
REMEMBER THE ABC INTERVIEW HE
DID THAT AIRED YESTERDAY?
GUESS WHY.
DURING HIS ATTEMPTED DAMAGE
CONTROL, HUNTER TOOK A WEEK SHOT
AT THE PRESIDENT'S SON, DON JR.,
WHO IS HERE TO RESPOND.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> I HAVE BEEN THROUGH SOME
REAL, REAL STUFFS.
THIS ISN'T REAL STUFF.
IT ISN'T.
IT TRULY ISN'T.
THAT PART OF IT, THE BARNUM &
BAILEY "SAY ANYTHING, DO
ANYTHING YOU WANT," LIKE DONALD
PRINCE HUMPERDINCK TRUMP, JR. IS
NOT SOMETHING I REALLY CARE
ABOUT.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION,
AUTHOR OF THE UPCOMING BOOK
"TRIGGERED."
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION, THE
PRESIDENT'S SON DONALD TRUMP JR.
I THINK YOU ARE THE SON MOST
LIKE THE FATHER.
>> I APPRECIATE IT.
IT TOOK 41 YEARS TO GET THERE.
HUNTER BIDEN HAS SOME OF THAT
FROM JOE.
HE ALSO MUMBLES TO ALL OF HIS
INTERVIEWS.
>> Sean: I'M GOING TO ASK.
I WANT YOU TO RESPOND FULLY.
HERE'S MY TAKE.
HE IS DUMB.
HE ADMITTED EVERYTHING THAT WE
KNEW.
HE ADMITTED NO EXPERIENCE,
UKRAINE, CHINA.
NO EXPERIENCE ENERGY, OIL, GAS.
NO EXPERIENCE PRIVATE EQUITY.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT -- HE
MISLED WHEN HE SAID NOT A PENNY.
WE KNOW HE'S GOT EQUITY.
HERE'S THE THING.
IF THIS WAS YOU AT AN E.U. OR
VICE PRESIDENT SON, DAD, SORRY
ABOUT THE DEMOTION.
IT WOULD BE NEVER ENDING
COVERAGE.
>> THE END OF THE WORLD.
BY THE WAY, IT'S NOT JUST THEN.
HOW ABOUT RIGHT OUT OF SCHOOL?
HE GETS A HIGH-PAYING JOB FROM
THE BIGGEST BANK AND THE LARGEST
EMPLOYER IN THE STATE OF
DELAWARE WHERE DADDY IS
CONVENIENTLY A SENATOR.
HE THEN GETS ON THE BOARD OF
AMTRAK.
1996.
HE WAS ABOUT 27.
>> Sean: WHAT WAS HIS
EXPERIENCE?
>> DAD TOOK THE TRAIN ONCE IN A
WHILE SO THAT MADE HIM QUALIFY.
IT NEVER ENDS.
THEN YOU HAVE THAT CHINA.
YOU HAVE UKRAINE.
MINOR PROBLEM: HE'S NEVER BEEN
IN ENERGY, DOESN'T SPEAK
UKRAINIAN.
MINOR DETAILS BUT IT'S OKAY.
BY THE WAY MORE PORTLY THAN
THAT, THEY WANT TO QUESTION MY
FAMILY.
IMAGINE BEING IN HIDING FOR A
MONTH LIKE HE'S BEEN SINCE WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS AND YOU
COME OUT AND THAT'S A NUMBER YOU
GIVE?
THAT IS GUILT IN AND OF ITSELF.
>> Sean: HE ADMITTED HE
WOULDN'T HAVE GOTTEN THE
MILLIONS BUT FOR HIS FATHER.
>> HE SET IT ON THE STAGE.
THEN JOE DENIES IT LATER ON IN
AND OF COURSE ANDERSON COOPER
DOESN'T CALM DESPITE THE FACT
THAT CNN, EVEN TO AN END, AND
SAID WELL, HUNTER CONTRADICTED
IT.
IT WAS PRETTY DISGUSTING.
LIKE YOU SAID, IF
DONALD TRUMP JR. TOOK $1.05 FROM
CHINA, NOT $1.5.1.5 BILLION.
WE WOULD SOLVE THE FAKE NEWS
MEDIA PROBLEM BECAUSE THEIR
HEADS WOULD EXPLODE AND THERE
WOULD BE NONE OF THEM LEFT.
IF I DID THAT FOR A NO-SHOW JOB
FOR $83,000 A MONTH IN UKRAINE,
NO PROBLEM.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
BIDENS AND US, WE WERE
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS PEOPLE
BEFORE POLITICS AND WE GIVE UP
DOING ALL NEW DEALS GOING
FORWARD.
WE DIDN'T BECOME MAGICALLY
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF OUR POLITICAL
POSITION.
WE PUT IT ALL ASIDE FOR YEARS.
>> Sean: EVEN YOUR BROTHER HAD
TO GIVE UP RAISING MONEY FOR
CANCER.
>> IT'S INSANE.
THE DOUBLE STANDARD IS
DESPICABLE.
THEY UTILIZE THAT PLATFORM WITH
A WINK, WINK.
JOE BIDEN HAS -- NO KNOWS
NOTHING ABOUT IT.
JOE BIDEN WILLING TO FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR BY THREATENING THE
GOVERNMENT WITH MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN AID IF THEY DON'T GET
RID OF THE GUY INVESTIGATING HIS
SON.
GIVE ME A BREAK SEAN.
IT NEVER ENDS AND THE FACT THAT
THEY ARE PRETENDING LIKE THIS
WASN'T -- HEY.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY THAT I'M
NOT PART OF WHO I AM BECAUSE MY
FATHER.
THAT WOULD BE FOOLISH.
OKAY.
BUT THE DIFFERENCES WE DID IT AS
CAPITALISTS.
WE DID IT AS BUSINESS PEOPLE.
WE DIDN'T DO IT PRETENDING UNDER
THE CLOAK OF JOE IS A GREAT
PUBLIC SERVANT.
HERE, SON.
HERE'S EVERY JOB YOU'VE EVER
HAD.
NOW THEY DO THE FAMILIES OFF
LIMITS.
KIDS ARE OFF LIMITS.
HUNTER BIDEN IS 50.
OKAY.
I WASN'T OFF-LIMITS WHEN IT
STARTED AT 38.
HUNTER BIDEN SHOULDN'T BE OFF
LIMITS NOW.
>> Sean: BARRON WAS TEN.
>> THEY'VE HAD NO PROBLEM GOING
AFTER HIM.
THEY'VE MADE COMMENTS ABOUT MY
CHILDREN.
THE DOUBLE STANDARD IS
DESPICABLE.
HEY, THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN US
AND THEM.
WHEN THERE'S A QUESTION, WE PUT
OUT THERE.
WHEN THEY SAY WHAT ABOUT THIS, I
PUT MY EMAILS OUT THERE.
HERE'S THE TRANSCRIPTION.
HOW ARE THEY DOING THE THINGS
UNDER THE CLOAK OF SECRECY?
ADAM SCHIFF HAS SEEN IT.
NO ONE NO ONE ELSE'S SEEN IT.
I'M STILL HEARING ABOUT IT.
HE HAS SEEN EVIDENCE.
THEY WON'T SHOW THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Sean: COLLUDING WITH A
RUSSIAN.
>> WHAT TO THEY HAVE TO HIDE?
WHY CAN'T THEY DO IT IN FRONT OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE LIKE WE'VE
BEEN DOING IT?
IT'S INSANE.
IT'S NOT FAIR.
AMERICAN SEE IT, SEAN.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE
ANY EXPERIENCE, WHICH HE
ADMITTED, AND YOU GET PAID ALL
THIS MONEY AND YOU ARE ADMITTING
IT'S BECAUSE YOUR DAD IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT, WARMTH AND GIVE
ALL THIS MONEY TO THIS AND,
CHINA AND UKRAINE, EXCEPT THAT
THEY ARE REALLY BUYING FAVOR
WITH THE FATHER.
IT'S THAT CLEAR.
>> OF COURSE THEY ARE.
WHEN YOU'RE THE FATHER AND YOUR
SON'S ENTIRE CAREER IS DEPENDENT
ON THEM, THEY OWN YOU.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
THEY BOUGHT BIDEN INC. AND THEY
HAVE BEEN DOING IT DOMESTICALLY
WHETHER IT WAS MBNA BANK,
AMTRAK, WHATEVER, DOMESTICALLY
WHEN HE WAS A SENATOR AND
HAD INFLUENCE OVER DOMESTIC
POLICY AND THEY STARTED DOING IT
INTERNATIONALLY.
THE SECOND JOE BIDEN BECAME
VICE PRESIDENT AND HAD AUTHORITY
ABROAD.
>> Sean: I WANT TO KNOW.
ALL OF THIS IS GOING ON WHAT
YOUR DAD, THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN
DISARRAY, THEY HAVE DONE NOTHING
FOR THREE YEARS THAT
REMOTELY LOOKS LIKE HELPING WITH
PEACE, PROSPERITY, SAFETY, AND
SECURITY.
THEN YOU HAVE THESE RADICAL 2020
DEMOCRATS THAT ARE TALKING ABOUT
94 TRILLION IN TEN YEARS.
36 TRILLION IN TEN YEARS.
I DON'T SEE THIS WORKING FOR
THEM.
I SEE THAT YOUR FATHER
SUPPORTERS WILL BE STRONGER THAN
2016.
>> I THINK WITHOUT QUESTION
BECAUSE HONESTLY PEOPLE EVEN IN
THE MIDDLE, THEY SEE THE
INSANITY.
THE OTHER SIDE DOESN'T TALK
ABOUT ISSUES.
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT
UNPRECEDENTED UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBER IS FOR EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC
IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY CERTAINLY DON'T TALK ABOUT
6.3 MILLION PEOPLE REMOVED OFF
OF THE FOOD STAMP ROLES BECAUSE
GUESS WHAT.
THOSE ARE PEOPLE NO LONGER
DEPENDENT ON GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
IF NANCY PELOSI MAYBE WOULD ACT
ON THE USMCA, THE DEAL THAT THEY
SAID NO ONE COULD EVER
RENEGOTIATE FAILED NAFTA.
MY FATHER DIDN'T BUT THEY WON'T
VOTE ON IT.
IT'S GOOD FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WHY WON'T THEY BRING IT UP?
BECAUSE THEY NEED IMPEACHMENT.
THEY CAN'T MEET HIM AT THE
BALLOT BOX SO THEY'VE GOT TO
CONTINUE THE HOAX.
>> Sean: A LOT OF PEOPLE ASK
ME, WHEN ARE YOU RUNNING?
>> I'M NOT.
MY FOCUS.
GET MY FATHER REELECTED FOR 2020
BECAUSE HE'S DOING AN INCREDIBLE
JOB.
HE'S DOING AN INCREDIBLE JOB
DESPITE UNPRECEDENTED --
THIS IS NEVER HAPPEN TO AN
AMERICAN PRESIDENT.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
IT'S A DISGRACE TO OUR REPUBLIC
AND OUR DEMOCRACY AND IT SHOULD
NEVER BE ALLOWED TO HAPPEN
AGAIN.
THE ONLY CURE FOR THAT TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME IS FOUR
MORE YEARS.
THAT'S WHY I'M STUDY MY TIME
TRAVELING ALL THE COUNTRY
CAMPAIGNING FOR HIM,
CAMPAIGNING FOR THOSE IN
CONGRESS AND IN THE SENATE AND
IN GOVERNOR SEATS WHO BELIEVE IN
HIM.
WE CAN DO THIS AND WE CAN GET
THIS COUNTRY ON THE RIGHT TRACK
AGAIN.
OUR ISSUES SHOULDN'T BE HOW MANY
OF THE 97 GENDERS ARE WE
DISCUSSING TODAY.
WE HAVE REAL PROBLEMS IN THIS
COUNTRY WE HAVE TO ADDRESS IT.